>> Juan: WELCOME BACK.
PROMINENT DEMOCRATS DEFENDING
JOE BIDEN AFTER HE ADAMANTLY
DENIED A SEXUAL ASSAULT
ALLEGATION AGAINST HIM BY FORMER
STAFFER TARA READE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE’S BEEN SO MANY
INVESTIGATIONS OF THE
VICE PRESIDENT.
THE MOST INCOME OF THE
COMPREHENSIVE INVESTIGATION OF
THE VICE PRESIDENT WAS WHEN HE
WAS VETTED BY BARACK OBAMA IN
2008.
BARACK OBAMA TRUSTED JOE BIDEN.
I TRUST JOE BIDEN.
>> JUST BECAUSE YOU’RE A
SURVIVOR DOESN’T MEAN THAT EVERY
CLAIM IS EQUAL.
IT MEANS WE GIVE THEM THE
ABILITY TO MAKE THEIR CASE.
THE OTHER SIDE AS WELL.
MAKE A JUDGMENT THAT’S INFORMED.
I DON’T BELIEVE THAT IT’S
CONSISTENT WITH THE JOE BIDEN I
KNOW WHEN I DO BELIEVE JOE.
>> IT’S INTERESTING THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO FAN
THIS THING ARE THE VERY PEOPLE
WHO SUPPORT DONALD TRUMP.
>> Juan: FORMER TOP OBAMA
ADVISOR DAVID AXELROD SAYS THE
ALLEGATION OF HARASSMENT NEVER
CAME UP DURING THE VETTING
PROCESS TO SELECT BIDEN AS
VICE PRESIDENT IN 2008.
NOW "THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS
TAKING HEAT AFTER SUGGESTING
THAT THE DNC INVESTIGATE THE
BIDEN SEXUAL ASSAULT CLAIM.
DANA, I WAS WONDERING, FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE, WHERE DO WE STAND
NOW?
WHAT DO YOU THINK IT IS?
WE’VE HAD DAVID AXELROD SAY IT
DIDN’T COME UP IN 2008 DURING A
VERY THOROUGH VETTING.
WE’VE HAD THE DENIAL LAST FRIDAY
FROM THE VICE PRESIDENT.
WHERE DO WE STAND?
>> Dana: WELL, I THINK YOU’RE
SEEING WHAT’S GOING TO HAPPEN,
AS ALL THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING
TO COALESCE BEHIND BIDEN.
I MENTIONED ON FRIDAY THAT IF
YOU DIDN’T SEE OVER THE WEEKEND
PROMINENT DEMOCRATS START TO
DISTANCE THEMSELVES FROM
JOE BIDEN THAT THAT MEANT THERE
HAVE BEEN A COLLECTIVE
AGREEMENT, MAY BE SPOKEN, MAY BE
SPOKEN SOMEWHERE.
THAT THEY ARE JUST GOING TO HAVE
TWO GO FOR IT, DEFEND JOE BIDEN
THEN CAME OUT WITH A COUPLE
THINGS.
ASKING THE DNC TO INVESTIGATE
JOE BIDEN WOULD’VE BEEN LIKE
ASKING HARVEY WEINSTEIN’S MOVIE
COMPANY TO INVESTIGATE HIM.
THAT DOESN’T WASH.
THIS IDEA THAT JOE BIDEN WAS
MORE VETTED BECAUSE HE WENT TO
THE 2008 VICE PRESIDENTIAL
VETTING THAN SOMEONE LIKE
BRETT KAVANAUGH WHEN MULTIPLE
SENATE CONFIRMATIONS FROM FOR
THE U.S. CIRCUIT COURT.
I KNOW THAT JUDICIAL APARTMENTS
ARE POLITICAL NOW BUT REMEMBER
WHEN HARRY REID WAS HEAD OF THE
DEMOCRATS THAN HE HAD THE
MAJORITY IN THE SENATE, THEY
WENT AFTER ALL OF THOSE
NOMINEES.
IF THEY COULD’VE PICKED UP
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, THEY
ABSOLUTELY WOULD HAVE USED IT.
THIS IS ALSO WHAT I THINK.
THE REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO GET USED TO THE IDEA
THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE NOT GOING
TO MAKE THIS HUGE ISSUE.
THEY DON’T MIND BEING CALLED
HYPOCRITES.
THEY ARE GOING TO GREEN, GET
THROUGH IT, AND WITHIN A WEEK OR
TWO, THEY WILL BE MOVING ON TO
SOMETHING ELSE.
>> Juan: JESSE, PICKING UP ON
DANA’S POINT, HAS THE WHOLE
CHARGE NOW BEEN EFFECTIVELY SORT
OF NEUTERED, IF YOU WILL?
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP?
OR DO YOU THINK THERE’S ANY WAY
HE CAN USE THIS POLITICALLY?
>> Jesse: HE WILL USE IT.
I MEAN THERE’S VULNERABILITIES
ON HIS SIDE BUT HE’LL USE IT.
HE’S NEVER BEEN AFRAID TO DO
THAT.
IT’S FUNNY THAT THEY THINK
BECAUSE OF A LA VETTED JOE THAT
THEY THINK HE’S CLEAN.
OBAMA CAN’T BET.
WHAT ABOUT JEREMIAH WRIGHT?
HE SAT IN THAT GUY’S PEWS FOR
DECADES AND DIDN’T KNOW HE WAS A
RACIST HATER.
THEN THERE’S GRETCHEN WHITMER.
WHEN SB 12 GOD TO MAKE HER CASE?
SHE HASN’T BEEN INVITED ON A
SHOW TO HAVE AN INTERVIEW.
THEN YOU HAVE ERIC HOLDER SAYING
IS IT INTERESTING THAT TRUMP
SUPPORTERS ARE FANNING THE
FLAMES?
BILL CLINTON SUPPORTERS WERE
FANNING THE KAVANAUGH FLAMES.
AND THEN THE DNC CHAIR SAYS
NOTHING TO SEE HERE, THIS IS
LIKE THE HILLARY EMAIL SCANDAL.
OKAY WHY DID HILLARY DELETE
30,000 EMAILS IF THERE WASN’T
ANYTHING TO SEE?
SPEAKING OF DELETING, THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS ADMITTED THEY
INTERVIEWED THIS WOMAN READE
LAST YEAR, SPIKED THE STORY AND
DELETED THE FILE.
AND NOW THE SECRETARY OF THE
SENATE SAYS YEAH, YOU KNOW THE
COMPLAINT THAT WE MAY OR MAY NOT
HAVE?
YOU CAN’T SEE IT BECAUSE IT’S
CONFIDENTIAL.
SO THE TWO PLACES WHERE THE
COMPLAINT COULD BE, EITHER IN
THE UNIVERSITY OF DELAWARE OR
THE SENATE FILE, YOU’RE NOT
ALLOWED TO LOOK INTO?
YOU’VE GOT TO BE KIDDING ME.
THIS THING IS NOT OVER BY A MILE
MILE.
>> Juan: DAGEN, I WAS GOING TO
DO A CALL FOR IT BUT I WILL DO
IT NOW BECAUSE WE ARE SHORT ON
TIME BUT THERE’S A POLL THAT
INDICATES MOST DEMOCRATS FAVOR
RIGHT NOW IF IT WAS UP TO THEM,
THE MASSACHUSETTS SENATOR
ELIZABETH WARREN TO BE THE
VICE PRESIDENT FOR JOE BIDEN.
WONDER IF YOU THINK ALL OF THESE
ALLEGATIONS OR THIS SPECIFIC
ALLEGATION, THERE’S NOT A BUNCH,
THERE’S ONE ALLEGATION AGAINST
BIDEN, IT’S GOING TO IMPACT THE
WAY THAT HE CALCULATES WHO’S
GOING TO BE HIS VP CHOICE?
>> Dagen: NO BECAUSE HE
ALREADY SETTLED ON A WOMAN AND
WHOMEVER HE PICKS IS GOING TO
HAVE TO STEP UP AND DEFEND IT.
I ASSUME THAT THE MEDIA, WHO
ALREADY FEEL KIND OF TOASTY AND
BUBBLY ON THE INSIDE WHEN THE
INTERVIEW JOE BIDEN WILL JUST
CHART SKIPPING THE QUESTION.
WHY THAN THE MORE THAN TWO DOZEN
INTERVIEWS THAT BIDEN DID BEFORE
FRIDAY AFTER TARA READE CAME OUT
WITH HER ALLEGATIONS
OF MARCH 25, YOU NEVER EVEN GOT
ASKED ABOUT IT.
I THINK THEY WILL PUT IT BACK TO
THAT.
IT WASN’T LONG AGO THAT
JOE BIDEN WASN’T IN FAVOR OF THE
ACCUSER HAVING A SAY IN A SEXUAL
ASSAULT ALLEGATION.
HE PUT PRESSURE ON UNIVERSITIES
AND COLLEGES IN THIS COUNTRY TO
BASICALLY REMOVE THOSE
PROTECTIONS FOR THE ACCUSED.
ACTUALLY CALLED ACCORDING TO
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
EDITORIAL, CALLED EDUCATION
SECRETARY BETSY DeVOS WHEN SHE
TRIED TO RESTORE DUE PROCESS ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES, CALLED HER AND
HER SUPPORTERS CULTURAL
NEANDERTHALS.
THAT’S WORTH MENTIONING.
>> Juan: GREG, I COME TO YOU
AS A MEDIA MASTER.
TARA READE HAS NOT AGREED TO
APPEAR ON TALK SHOWS.
SO WOULD YOU THINK THAT’S ABOUT?
HOW DO YOU COVER IT IF SHE’S NOT
COMING BACK ON TELEVISION?
>> Greg: I DON’T KNOW.
THIS WAS PUT UP BY GLENN
GREENWALD’S GROUP.
IT’S NOT REPUBLICANS PUSHING
THIS.
IT’S PROGRESSIVE.
I SAW A PROMINENT NEED TO LAWYER
-- ME TO LAWYER, DOING AN OPEN
TWEET TO THE ACCUSER SAYING I
BELIEVE YOU, TARA READE, BUT
I’M STILL SUPPORTING JOE BIDEN.
EVEN ADMITTED HE HAS A HISTORY
OF TOUCHING PEOPLE.
BASICALLY SAYING IT’S NOTHING
PERSONAL AND I THOUGHT HOW AWFUL
THAT WAS UNTIL I REALIZED HOLY
CRAP, SHE’S REALLY HONEST.
SHE’S ACTUALLY AN HONEST
LIBERAL.
SHE’S DOING THE OPPOSITE OF ALL
THE OTHER DEMOCRATS, SHE IS
SAYING I KNOW HE’S GUILTY BUT
I’M STILL GOING TO SUPPORT HIM
BECAUSE I HATE TRUMP.
AT LEAST SHE’S BEING HONEST.
EVERYBODY ELSE HAS TO BITE THEIR
TONGUE BECAUSE THEY WANT TO BE
VP.
THEY ALL WANT TO BE
VICE PRESIDENT.
TO ALL THE WOMEN, THEY ARE GOING
I SUPPORT JOE BIDEN EVEN THOUGH
WE’VE HEARD EVERYTHING THAT
EVERYBODY ELSE WAS HEARD.
FINALLY, WE STILL HAVEN’T
FIGURED OUT HOW TO DEAL WITH
THIS STUFF IN GENERAL.
HOW DO YOU FIGHT THIS IN THE
PUBLIC SQUARE.
IF HE’S INNOCENT, IF JOE IS
INNOCENT AS KAVANAUGH WAS, THEN
THIS IS UNFAIR AND DAD.
IT’S AWFUL FOR HIM.
IF HE’S GUILTY, THAT HE MUST GO.
BUT IT’S WEIRD.
WE JUST DON’T HAVE A SOLUTION
FOR THAT, DO WE?
SO LIKE DANA SAYS YOU HAVE THIS
BACK AND FORTH AND THEN IN A
WEEK WE’LL MOVE ON.
AS IF IT NEVER HAPPENED, LIKE A
WEIRD, LIKE A WEIRD HANGOVER.
IT’S JUST GONE.
WE DON’T SOLVE IT.
NOBODY REALLY CARED.
>> Juan: I THINK PEOPLE CARE
BUT YOU’RE RIGHT.